yeah he had the best stories man he's
time out when you know he's a young man
then he was you know doing his thing and
he was in this long-distance
relationship because he grew up in
Oakland and his arch nemesis was Clint
Eastwood and he said this is how he
became arch-nemesis cuz clean Clint
Eastwood I guess was a good football
player in high school and he played for
the rival high school and then he was
dating this girl in LA and they they he
would fly back and forth and do his
stuff and he was like you know I figured
we were do dating and you know I'd see
her multiple times a month and four
months and stuff like Daniels and then
I'm over a house you know we just got
done doing the I think said the shebang
I'm like okay and he goes in she's in
the shower of the phone ringing he was
the phone when he's back then a phone
ring isn't it was answer phone and it
was a guy and he goes answer fire hello
and he the guy say he goes well who's
this is this pact spiel it's who's this
goes this Clint Eastwood because that's
how I found out she was cheating um no
yeah son of a [ __ ] so buddy that's
tough that's nice you gotta be like you
win all right thank you thank you yeah
easily
Jesus yeah packed up the best stories
man the best stories Eastwood back in
the day with such a baby was so is packs
though yeah what does this girl look
like that's what I want to add to what I
want to know oh dude look that second
picture in chin come on do how mean I
cannot be max compete what can they do
yeah dime P ed well straight up movie
star
his son looks just like I'm right yes
god that's good yeah yeah yeah oh wow
he's not Scott's not his big toe nice
tall yeah like Clint like tall like dude
they look well clinched all and Clint's
also a musician and a director and he
does it all and the Clint would score
his own mutant movies what yeah
definitely
they don't make this might not anymore
do they no they don't buddy no they
don't Clint Jesus Christ you lay the
piano oh yeah really well
piano and actually compose I mean did
the scores for his movies there's some
guys that you see like this just like
what a [ __ ] town
I know it's just like it's it's
unbelievable yeah you got like Paul
Newman him you know you there's so
character just like the jack of all
trade just like guys guy yeah just
everything they did they don't miss now
good-looking take care of themselves
there and so and six three yes there's
no more like real Hollywood celebs like
that now no now he was just a massive
movie star we're talking I think that's
all great Charles right yep Wow yeah I
think I Clint Eastwood wrote directed
and starred in his own movie the lot of
them you'll well he also did like last
year dude he's 91 High Plains Drifter
the I mean what is it called for
Unforgiven I mean he's got it goes on
not as the good the bad and the ugly
this is my generation and even before
yeah well no joke
I'll tell you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]